at the peak of her power in Europe angle
immaculate found herself caught up in a
political storm
in the summer of 2015 a growing number
of migrants crossed the Serbian
Hungarian border thousands got stranded
in Budapest but hundreds of thousands
were determined to make it to Germany
the German Chancellor opened her
country's borders on humanitarian
grounds Yama's Ophelia's keshava chiffon
does a now iconic phrase and one that
initially earned her praise the world
over but then in some countries of
central eastern europe there was a fear
and anger about how little they had been
consulted before she had decided to open
the borders and let immigrants and
refugees in mecca called for solidarity
and for the refugees to be fairly
distributed across Europe countries like
Hungary refused Prime Minister Viktor
Orban prepared for a fully-fledged power
struggle the Germans tried forcing the
issue by demanding a vote in a dramatic
meeting of interior ministers in
Brussels a majority ended up deciding in
favor of limited refugee quotas but this
did not change the situation on the
ground most migrants continued to get
stuck in Greek caps heads of state
ministers come here decide this is what
we are going to do and then they go home
and it's actually not happening and I
think that's a huge issue for the
European Union we have to do what we
decide together otherwise the whole
credibility and the stability and power
of the construction is gone
which is exactly what happened a number
of countries started to rebel against
nackles policy austria and the Balkan
states closed their borders in
interviews Mackel seemed undeterred but
she was largely isolated and effectively
the border closures were helping her she
now put all her efforts into a deal with
Turkey to prevent refugees from
illegally getting to Europe in the first
place and it worked for some time at
least the numbers of migrants arriving
at the Greek Coast dropped dramatically
but Europe remains deeply divided as
matka pushed the EU to the brink with
her welcome policy well I think it
really goes to father that assessment I
am I starting point would be that the
refugee crisis would have been there
even without Marcos the impulse of the
reflex to respond to it at a European
level and with a European strategy i
think is still the right one but it
can't be implemented the political storm
might have passed for now the
differences in europe remain however not
least over this phrase young Sophie we
can do it
storm could re-emerge at any time
you